i'm not sure whether it says more about
the pointlessness of the previously on
segments or the terrible action cutting
but i can't even tell the difference
between this edited down action in the
original cut to hell action so let's go
ahead and send both dc comics i i mean
marvel uh comcast i think the dark side
of my sim brain is warring with my
non-sin brain it's like my own personal
star wars huh when i come up with those
two words opening up your show with
fishing might as well be opening it up
on people attending church or a soccer
match it's as if the writers were like
how can we bore our viewers to the point
of them wanting to scratch their eyes
out right from the get-go also these
alien krill are about the brightest
electric blue possible which for an
animal that's probably very tasty and
easy to catch doesn't make a lot of
evolutionary sense if only darwin had
space travel and lived in the distant
past we could have avoided all of this
this is terrible frog catching technique
everyone knows you have to catch from
the top front of the frog not the back
then you hold it gently by the sides
while it relieves itself as a defense
mechanism at which point you let it go
because you can't stand the thought of
terrorizing a small animal it's like in
the frog catching manual and everything
take that woven gourd-shaped object
droid murder druer only on movies and tv
do people absolutely terrified of death
from an intruder stop hiding immediately
after the bad guy leaves it's not like
they were suffocating under there those
two would have stayed underneath that
basket for another five minutes at least
before slowly raising it up and sneaking
away but sure let's go with the
violently discard safety while the bad
guy's still likely an earshot strategy
not completing your a's those are upside
down v's disney upside down consummate
fees stop touching things
[Laughter]
but also kids no population density real
backwater skuggle that's scugist what
you don't know what a skug is consider
your ignorance part of the problem go
educate yourself you ready to lay low
and stretch your legs for a couple of
months you little whomp rat either
manual has a sense of humor or he
doesn't show plays so fast and loose
with his emotional output i've got worse
whiplash than a bola tour playing with a
high low ball you stay right here you
stay attempting to leave miners alone in
a parked vehicle
not keeping your battery or chicken leg
pug cat in check and yes i know it has
an actual name but my version is more
accurate and you know it well you're in
luck i just took down a gringer so
there's plenty oh a gringer you say i'm
certain we all know what that is and how
it'd be taken down by you so we fully
understand what all of this means look
if there's one thing i'm consistent
about it's that these shows need more
exposition sheesh keep an eye on the kid
yes sir not vetting your baby yoda
sitters next thing you know a
ghostbuster's doing some housework for
you and catchers are breastfeeding the
little guy and it's all downhill from
there i know how this stuff works what
on earth i mean what on sorghum is this
scanning for can't be heat right because
there's no way this amount of heat would
still be left after brief walking
contact with a shoe and if it's just
looking for indentations in the ground
can you do that with a naked eye perhaps
the show wants us to believe it's some
mystical microbial remnant that's on the
bottom of everyone's shoes that manual
can scan but it's clearly playing it to
look like some sort of heat signature
remnant so i'll send it on the confusion
alone
helmet punching will always be a sin but
when it's best car helmet punching i'm
going with five both combatants pull
their guns to shoot but then don't for
some reason cough cough plot armor cough
cough and then just hold the guns in a
pointless standoff cliche cue moment but
how did gregory get down from the chair
with the porridge amanda had to pick him
up and put him in the chair when they
got to the establishment let's just call
it an early retirement call whatever you
want gina i mean cara unless you want to
go another round one of us is gonna have
to move on and i was here first why is
this though the whole reason cara and
mando picked this place is because it's
not on anyone's radar what does it
matter if both of them are there this
feels like unnecessary conflict which
makes it very necessary to award a sin
to the middle of nowhere
where do you live i could send that this
information is enough to change mando's
firm no to a yes but instead i'm gonna
send the phrase middle of nowhere there
is no middle of nowhere in fact there is
no nowhere do you know where nowhere is
your line is nowhere i was driving up do
you know where nowhere is
nowhere is just a small separation away
from now here my point is mando is
wishy-washy good thing mando knew
exactly in the woods where cara was and
it was close by convenient future work
buddy camping site is convenient
damn it grogu you basically have no
relevance to this episode but disney's
using you as some get out of boring free
card by just throwing in your
unrelenting cuteness every once in a
while even though it has nothing to do
with this discount hidden fortress
episode not saying it isn't working i'm
just saying it's unfair amanda has
lightning speed reflexes here and almost
shoots this little girl but earlier
didn't even turn around when the two
villagers wrote up to him at the razor
crest nor did he even notice grogu was
approaching him until he was standing
right next to mando before they went
into the village is it the helmet or
just plot selective peripheral vision
can i feed him i give all the sins back
if right after he says yes she quickly
finishes her sins with to the mamacore
as a ritual sacrifice i don't think
they'll be fine oh sure leaving me in
the ship alone or with a random gringer
murderer is fine but the second a little
girl wants a playdate he goes straight
into fluttercraft parenting mode let us
know if there's anything you need she
100 wants his best scar spear and he's
not even going to react i get all the
this is the way stuff but he only has to
leave the helmet on right do
mandalorians take a vow of celibacy i
don't care about the answer i will not
be denied random mando
[Music]
wait what he can take that off in front
of an open window with kids playing
right outside how is this not the
mandalorian version of indecent exposure
about 15 or 20 of them came through here
on foot but when if they're tracking
where the crew of raiders headed that
attacked the village a couple of days
ago these heat signatures would have
easily cooled off by now bull technology
continues to be bullsh and something big
sheared off those branches yeah think
did your fancy exposition vision help
you with that brilliant insight we're
not leaving stubbornness sure in movies
and tv it always seems to somehow work
but in real life you just end up tearing
a rotator cuff when the jar pickles
won't budge but you refused to use the
hair dryer trick your girlfriend found
on the internet these people should end
up dead or at least eating pickles
one-handed we're gonna need to dig real
deep right here cara and mando will
proceed to talk about this trap along
with the need to cut down trees and
build barricades with them not to
mention they have to train a group of
farmers how to be combat ready these are
tasks that would probably take at least
a week if not longer to complete but i
have to assume only takes a day or two
and if we're supposed to believe that a
week or two has passed then the village
got extremely lucky they weren't raided
again either way i'm pretty sure there's
some [ __ ] in here to send somewhere
also this episode spends as much time on
its training montage as a two hour movie
like shang qi and we don't even get an
aquafina miracle kill shot out of it
great work your combination of
braggadocio arrogance and propensity for
wasting ammo is gonna come in real handy
later when your tribe runs out of shots
because you decided to kill that pan 20
times america radioactive milk this
grapples on incoherently for some time
if carl was correct earlier and the
villagers already knew about the atsd
then how were any of these trees that
it's currently taking down still
standing look there are plenty of parts
of this plan that are pure panther and
should never work but this part actually
should there's no way the driver of this
thing got this close to the trap and
then mid step looked down and figured it
out i believe it if he had spotted it a
ways out but this timing is clearly
meant to drive up the tension not the
reality get down get down starting a
cool in the gang song without getting to
the jungle boogie part also even though
everyone was told to get down cabin and
stoke are still raised up and deserve to
die but won't so what exactly was the
plan before cara dune but not that dune
went up and shot the eye out of the atsd
if it had stepped into the water
originally was amanda just going to run
up there and try a bomb on the outside
of the head it's gonna break his little
heart strumming the shrimp with their
fingers
singing wildlife with their words
krilling him softly with this song
krillin himself he'll get over it we all
do parental abandonment oh yeah that's
an easy thing to get over i mean wait
what i will look after him as one of my
own for the next 50 or 60 years at which
point i'll die and he will still be a
toddler but i totally got this dunas ex
machina the surest way to know you're
watching quality star wars these days is
when you see these five beautiful words
at the end of the episode instead of
this
we get this
let me ask you a question why the hell
were we ambushed huh does anybody have
any tape out there i want to put some
tape over the death button
don't touch anything
[Music]
sir i've read a lot about your people
what do you mean you people i'm gonna
need one more thing it's just we're
putting new cover sheets on all the tps
reports before they go out now so if you
could go ahead and try to remember to do
that from now on do you mind if i ask
you something
go ahead how long has it been since
you've taken that off tobias was a never
nude which is exactly what it sounds
like first lesson sticking with the
pointy end
you'll shoot your eye out kid